let's get into this week's hatred mail
if this is your first foray into the
cesspool that is hatred mail here's a
little introduction
[Music]
it's like a mandatory transvaginal
ultrasound for your mind Patriot mail
written by Patriots who hate David
Pakman because America and because
freedom sometimes I introduced the
specifics of hatred mail sometimes I
don't this week hatred mail really needs
no introduction so I won't introduce it
you are racism obviously you didn't
sexually assault anyone no one as beta
as you would assault anything I had a
dream last night David Pakman
demonetised on YouTube and on Twitter
just wishful thinking
idiots David Pakman is 100% pure break
[ __ ] boy betta [ __ ] you're such a tit I
like that I there's no way I would ever
be accused of assaulting anyone because
I'm simply too beta to ever assault
anyone
I liked the alliteration at the end I
just wish he kept it going for a little
it should have gone on like 10 or 20
adjectives for sure big thing is coming
up with hatred mail you were going to
have an opportunity to be heard on the
topic of hatred mail in a very serious
manner
Wow without being a hatred you're still
about being a hatred yourself that's
exactly right I'll talk to you more
about that in a couple of weeks and of
course you can use the coupon code hey
tree at 40 h8 e RI ot for zero to save
40% off of your membership at WWN
pakman.com 206 hey tree it's cry every
time you use the coupon code hey tree at
40